más que nunca la humanidad sufre el
calentamiento global Que ella misma
provoca según la Organización
meteorológica Mundial en 2022 las olas
de calor extremo las sequías históricas
las inundaciones devastadoras y los
incendios arrasadores han azotado el
planeta sin tregua afectando a millones
de personas y prueba de que el cambio
climático no Da señales de desacelerar
los últimos años han sido los más
calurosos jamás registrados los últimos
ocho años han sido los más cálidos
registrados a nivel mundial impulsados
por el aumento constante de las
concentraciones de gases de efecto
invernadero y del calor acumulado en
2022 la temperatura media mundial era
aproximadamente de 1,15 grados Celsius
superior a los niveles preindustriales
es el octavo año consecutivo en que se
supera esta marca de 1 ºC y desde los
años 80 cada década ha sido más cálida
que interior como recuerda el
ambientalista Maximiliano bello para
France 24 el 2022 Fue entonces
un año que tuvo una temperatura mucho
mayor que el promedio Qué significa eso
Entonces que la temperatura
efectivamente viene subiendo que haya
sido más baja tal vez que otros años
previos
es probablemente solamente una
coincidencia gracias a la niña un
fenómeno meteorológico que tiende a
bajar la temperatura de los océanos y
que lleva causando estragos desde 2020
el calentamiento se dio atenuado el
fenómeno podría prolongarse hasta marzo
antes de ser seguido por un período
neutro sin el niño ni la niña pero si
vuelve el fenómeno del niño el riesgo
sería que se suba otro importante
escalón en el calentamiento glo